Well, to see how this plays out,
first I'm going to show you what the JavaScript actually does.
Here I've typed it out.
Here's our webpage with embedded JavaScript in it.
We declare the function mymin of a and b.
If a is less than b, return a. Otherwise return b.
We declare the function square to take x and return x squared.
And then we called document.write of mymin of the square of -2 and the square of 3.
Well, -2 times -2 is 4.
3 times 3 is 9.
4 is smaller than 9, so we expect 4 to be returned,
and 4 is returned.
How happy are we? So happy.
All right, now we're going to get this same thing, a 4, in Python.
All right, and now we're back at our Python interpreter,
and I'm going to type out the same code starting here.
Note again that in Python, instead of the opening and closing curly braces,
we have tabbing and colons.
We also don't necessarily need to terminate our statements with semicolons.
The Python equivalent of document.write is print, and we print out the 4.
Exactly what we wanted to see.
Let's actually go try something out.
Let's go put in a bunch of extra gratuitous semicolons in Python
to make it look a little bit more like JavaScript.
What do we think will happen?
In fact, nothing special happens.
Python is totally fine with you terminating statements with semicolons if you would like.
You just don't have to.
If you want to get in the habit of it in order to make it easier to transition
between Python and JavaScript, no problem.